That's step number 3, profile and comments.
So, what we are doing here, it's try to fill your profile with the name Avatar Interface Language.
Yeah, in aesthetics.
There's nothing, there's not a lot what to do.
"Translation language, same as interface language, change that."
"So this is so I can have display language be one, then I can set a default translation language if I'm in a medium."
"Rejoin dialogue."
Этим цветом.
Я не знаю, что это делается в том, что это делается ночью, но я не знаю, что это делается в темпе, но я не знаю, что это делается.
В темпе, я думаю, что я надеюсь, что я на солнце в темпе.
Разберем.
Дальше.
Ну, я не могу видеть, где я изменился к теме, я думаю, что может быть что-то что-то делать на вашей серии.
Я имею в виду следующую степь, чтобы менять язык?
Какие?
Да, я вижу.
Я думаю, что нужно менять язык в вашей серии.
Следующее степь - найти кнопку, чтобы менять язык или патч.
If you are struggling to find the button to change the language, you need to comment everything.
So, in settings, this is where I presume it would be.
There is something to change the translation language.
It doesn't change the language of the text.
It just sets a default related language to be.
Imagine settings also doesn't show anywhere to change the language of the website.
Integration.
To find where I would change the language of the website.
Субтитры сделал DimaTorzok
Это не так, да?
Угу.
Я не могу найти ни кнопки, чтобы изменять язык на аппеля.
На данный пункт на пункт на пункт на пункт.
Давайте идем на следующий этап.
Следующий этап - "Create Team".
У меня нет никакого идея, как я делаю.
Я хочу создать чат, чат, и отправить мне "invite" link.
Я вам отправил милейку.
I just received the intermittent meeting link from Oskar Murray
Its email contains only the link without any other text
I'll try to open this link
The link opened, it shows me camera setup with the calm music on the background
So I can choose a mic, it actually works
На спикер-тест, мою музыку стало очень громко.
Я вижу, что язык русский.
Теперь я нажму на кнопку "Join the meeting".
Я ждал, ждал, ждал, ждал.
Я ждал, ждал.
Я в этом meeting.
Сигало, в этом месте.
Это мы в этом месте.
Следующий степь, следующий степь, let's leave this room, we see the Invite links working.
I'll try to open the Invite link again.
"Oskar, are you left the meeting?"
I use the same link to join the meeting.
You can do that.
I'm passing all the presets with the microphone and camera.
I'm joining the meeting.
I joined it without permission.
Are you still here?
Alright, on your meeting page, I think you have a list of a meeting, our recent one.
Try to delete this link, this meeting.
And now try to open the same link for a meeting.
This meeting escaped from my site on my meeting, on my meeting page.
So I don't see any meetings with Oscar.
So now I use the same link to join the meeting.
Now I see a camera set up and microphone.
Сейчас я ждал, но митинг уже deleted от программы.
Также никто не может позволить митинг, потому что митинг не существует.
Давайте создать второй митинг.
Я создал митинг.
И отправил митинг в Оскар.
Митинг на митинг.
Митинг сейчас.
Поп-up от Оскар Муреи wants to join.
I can deny or admit.
The next part is to change the role.
I will give role admin to the Oscar,
but I can't find any button for that.
Let's check in a meeting settings.
We have no button to grant admin role to Oscar.
Let's pause this step.
Let's leave meeting.
Митин, мы're finished with this step.
Okay, now I'll stop recording.